I've been to Ono's before but that
sounds like no no no the answer her
answer is no who knows does not count
[Music]
I've heard deep dish is amazing but I've
only had like the Pizza Hut style of
Chicago deep-dish pizza I don't really
know what's different about it I think
there's like more sauce on the top it's
been shipped in to us from Chicago
oh please you try it
hell yeah we should try it dude
delicious mmm but you pull on there like
a cheese sandwich that much cheese in
one slice that's heaven you can see the
layer of cheese
yeah is it supposed to be like that I
like the tomato on the top I was iffy
about it I've been changed I'm converted
I feel like I'm eating tomatoes instead
of having like marinara sauce spread on
it this feels like a pizza that just
like made it made a clear decision I
love that it doesn't pretend to be
healthy
this pizza makes me feel that the thin
crust is just taking your money this is
great for pie this is a delicious dinner
pie I'm not even sure if you can call it
like pizza it's just like a different
beast I feel like I thought I knew what
pizza was there's a whole world of heats
out there if this type of pizza was
everywhere I would never buy thin crust
again if it's convenient I will have it
it's not a lollipop a John's Pizza Hut I
would go with New York Pizza any day but
this is awesome and I would totally eat
it again I like it better than New York
Pizza as far as I'm concerned
Chicago you're doing it right this is
like he want to go on a date night in
Chicago Chicago sounds kind of sexy so I
would go on that date